Oh what is going on YouTube check it out
so this week I know you guys have been
asking a lot for these condom style like
extra bloopers but we shot this on the
red and there wasn't any audio for it so
I don't actually have sound so what I'm
going to do is kind of give you a little
social commentary on what's going on in
the video conceptually we wanted this
video to be just like not just like but
to mimic the original video as much as
possible oops somebody Facebook
messaging all the beach scenes in the
video were very to say it was very hard
on me because I had a booty pop in in
public in front of Children and Families
while they're having picnics and [ __ ]
outside for about two hours and I
understand how some of you girls are
like hoes because my little back was
sore for like three days booty poppin so
for all you hoes out there good job or
bad job
if you can see at Buddha PO 2 which is a
Korean barbecue spot in k-town one of my
favorite places to go y'all should go
check that place out we had Gio from
just K films right we had art and show
right and then we also had Captain your
win at the table and from across one
that was me Chris and dumb and this
scene it actually is one of my favorites
because Cathy killed this part and
there's a part of the song that goes
going you want my sausage e and I just
might let you she grabs a sausage like
it's like a penis you know that she puts
them right on the grill I don't know I
was like the funniest part of the video
until the part was really funny because
when we had dumb we were trying to like
tell all these guys how to do that part
so we wanted them to be perfect so I
looked and um it was like dumb in this
part you have to be a creeper tingle on
a second let me see if I remember how to
do this
craziest part was very interesting
because he actually kind of freestyle
his own part where he looked at his
pepper and pepper and creators caught
you and coaches also penis Chris you
decided to go ahead and freestyle apart
and kind of look very you know very
self-conscious about his weird-looking
penis or pepper if you know it's roughly
about 26 or 27 seconds into the video
there is a there is a part where I'm on
the roof ledge and I'm pelvic thrusting
Anna
kind of go ahead that bot bottle was
probably the most difficult shot of all
I'm definitely afraid of heights so dan
dan Fisher the guy who actually uh shot
and edited this whole video and directed
this video so he go look to me and we're
talking on the phone and the guy goes
David I need you to do something for me
I need you to stand on top of the ledge
and pelvic thrust for five seconds now
mind you I would imitate or basically
relay what I was saying to him on the
phone but there'll be a lot of just be
throughout the whole video because I
hate his [ __ ] guts if you guys
notice that we did that we imitated the
part where side is in that tunnel and
he's kind of dancing you know kind of
going at that thing and we had like
garbage flying in my face
if you guys didn't notice that area is
like the dislike where the LA River is
or as I like to call it hobo's pissed
Creek we originally in that scene to
what we're having stuff flying in our
face we have flour done but then it was
too like Toleration we couldn't see it
so we had a scrap that part I wasn't the
only person Ellis actually ambushed in
this video if he knows we redid the the
sauna scene and Jason Jason Chen he's a
hobo what line also part of my acapella
group called the runs check it out runs
music shameless plug yeah but seriously
coach except Jason we didn't tell him
that he was going to be shirtless and
you know doing this little you know
little popping thing you know doing that
thing going on but he did it anyways
good sport he had a tattoo of myself on
his chest which I understand that most
ladies and men do want a replica of it
you know contain yourself ladies Jason
was such a good sport he did that Joseph
Vincent came through my homeboy love to
do the death decided to be let me go and
do a little homo head rest on his
shoulder like ah just like it yeah the
song I sing was really hard because we
couldn't stop laughing and it was it was
probably it was just very hard to find
us on in the first place that would let
us shoot there on top of that path
camera while not having the sauna run
which would destroy you know the camera
equipment of stuff so we actually had
Danielle who produced this this video
for us Daniel Lee she asked me to
specifically shout her out shamelessly
as she's sitting right here and laughing
throwing a pillow at me and of course
once again I had the homies of Bart and
Joe come through and barn Joe played
their Asian backyard just from me and
they exploded throughout the way which
is which was hilarious al what part of
the video I'm not sure if you guys
conduct crank me up personally was when
I was his chillin on the floor in the
BART this is random piece on the right
behind my head I thought that was
actually hilarious I'm not sure if you
guys caught that I thought it was funny
but I thought it was funny if you didn't
you go [ __ ] yourself if you notice
throughout throughout the music video I
had a lot of different clothes changes
so we got all these from like thrift
stores and all these other previous
wardrobes that I had four other skits I
went through a but Jillian like clothes
changes but I guess it was not worth it
I sweated through every single one like
a disgusting fat creature all for you
guys so and of course there was the
notorious pink tank top green suspenders
gold shorts scene that was Baba you know
first of all how many of you were
offended by that I'm not sorry because I
was the one who had to be in it and all
my street cred disappeared I looked like
a gay Jolly Rancher so um haha if you
thought it wasn't fun from you guys to
watch it wasn't fun for me to do either
I was out there luckily it was actually
at one of a girlfriends of mine Tony's
place so it was actually hidden and I'm
pretty sure people around the hill saw
what I was doing and probably threw up
in the mouth a little bit
originally that same funny enough was
actually supposed to be done basically
butt-naked and pink underwear which I
actually haven't
getting us notice these quadruple XL
pink panties that I was supposed to win
it and I stayed y'all from from a lot of
horrid nightmares and a lot of therapies
so uh you're welcome
then we have the the scene where there
was a subway seen in the original video
where he's dancing slow-mo towards her
kind of going like this and also they
meet each other I keep they lock he
touches her face something look
intensely the eyes but of course I'm a
pervert so in this one she had a run the
hell away but originally you guys saw
that there was a black man - just what
you wanted which is his penis once again
but the original idea was supposed to
have a mosaic blur and I was wearing
flesh color panties I'm talking I had
his boxers boobs I was wearing flesh
colored boxers and it was supposed to be
this huge mosaic blood of my penis
swinging around but I'll just pray the
video was gonna get flagged so I decided
not to do it if you're wondering who the
dancers by the way is a good friend of
my unit she's an amazing singer dancer
actress choreographer everything as such
that she does she's a little bit of
everything huh she came through really
well for this - the dancing did the
choreography for our video actually in
the last day and also throughout the
earlier parts of the video - so shout
out to Eunice thank you very much for
coming through and of course if you guys
notice on the last scene is where we
were doing the huge dance scene where
how fat what else is actually where they
filmed inception so it was the inception
warehouse shout out to Raymon and
Donnelly for securing the location for
us and letting us use it so much love
for you have no idea but this was dope
as hell we got short notice we had all
these dancers come through there's so
many names shout out this it's actually
on the list but can
all your homies and stuff like that and
also Julie's almost there once again Ali
Maki was there and she came through the
stereotypes were there you know my boy
stereotypes Kim Jong Il a Travis garland
my boy a length for a OS was there so it
was a dopest hell super super dope
dancing scenes I mean it was it was
really fun and the funny big part of us
did you guys didn't see there was
actually a clip of me when I was
actually in the dance circle and I
decided with my busted ass ankle to do
the splits and when I gonna split my
pants torn hat I was just like ah
swinging around we decided not to put
that in must again this is something
that I did for you guys specifically
because you guys requested it so much so
for any of you to say that AHA how much
they have a hat or not so once again
thank you guys for uh you know actually
requesting this video so by the way I
actually did this video because you
requested it so much that I decided to
do this I mean parodies usually aren't
my thing I don't do parodies I
especially don't like to wear gold booty
shorts and pink tank tops but this
specifically for you so for those of you
who say I don't read my comments I do
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and I sacrifice my
body and [ __ ] for this so I'm glad y'all
enjoyed it and if you didn't enjoy it I
hope you jump off a bridge into a bed of
syringes so that's basically it for the
commentary hope you guys enjoy this
video if y'all didn't then what can I
say
wait till next week I got more stuff
coming your way my bad that this videos
like this week but I'm a busy man what
can I do be sad
Oh pop contests are